Hello, this is the Hari-Tantei office.
We will accept any request.If necessary, we will do our best to solve the problem, such as carrying luggage and undercover investigations.
Dimensional investigations are an exception, of course, but that's police work
.
But don't study
too much Ms. Lee brought your luggage
[music]
[music] You
can take a picture with a nice teacher's new car
Where did you get all this money?
If you borrow money from the black market, be careful not to get killed Don't be
underestimated.
Thanks to everyone, I was able to repay the loan and buy a new car.
What a kind boss,
hurry up and carry your luggage." What's wrong with the
vacation
? Spring is here now
Adult love, my
heart is pounding
Let's go Let's show off the charm of a middle-aged man
I'm looking at the house  It's just a
kind of elegant taste It's
over Let's play beach volleyball Be
careful not to overdo it
I'm fine I
'm going to play in the
water  It's a
special energy drink
[music]
[applause]
[applause] The
beach is closed,
so please take your bags home
[music]
I am
It's been a
long time
[music]
Thank
you.
[MUSIC]
Throw away that thing
Maybe there's still a way to use it,
right?